this is why I think that the Joe Biden
FBI raid is actually a cover-up Daily
Mail reports what else are they hiding
White House claims transparency face
even White House claims of transparency
face even more scrutiny as it's revealed
National Archives was blocked from
releasing statement on classified
documents founded Biden's Think Tank the
Revelation came during question
questioning of archives general counsel
Gary Stern by top Republican James Comer
it raises questions over who stopped the
release from going public that is to say
just before the midterms when they
raided Biden's home and they they knew
he had these documents the National
Archives were barred by someone
it'd have to be either Biden or Merit
Garland they said do not make a
statement you are barred from doing so
that means when the midterms came
everybody
nobody had the opportunity to learn this
CBS News eventually reports it and
that's how we find out and now we're
actually getting some some information
as to what's going on now there there's
more raids there's more searches when it
can affect the Democrats exactly and
this this says to me if it's Garland or
if it's Biden
they're covering it up well if someone
asked the National Archives to cover it
up for sure 100 if the archives were
asked not to report they were asked to
come and that means it was Biden or
Garland
so maybe the Deep state is going after
Biden and he said no no don't let him
don't let anyone find out they're coming
after me I don't believe it because
they're all deep state they're all
establishment what likely happened is
they said we're going to use this
against Trump the documents but we got
to make sure you're clean before we make
that move so we're going to have the FBI
come in and search if they can find
anything and then we'll move forward
with Trump
then they inadvertently found stuff how
the story went yeah when when did they
raid Trump's house
yeah was it November it's an important
question was it before or after August
8th August 8th are they ready Trump's
house over the summer yeah so I I kind
of think they were like hey look this is
a big story and they're trying to say
maybe they do want Biden to run and they
were like if they go if if they go hard
on this Trump can't run for president
because of these documents we got to
make sure Biden doesn't have the same
problem
lo and behold he does
interesting I don't know what do you
think I think it's a malicious cover-up
a beneficial cover-up thing going back
to the Deep State thing what other
motives would the Deep State have in
getting rid of Biden aside from you know
he's not good for the Democrats I can't
think of any other motives because he's
doing exactly what they want them and
they don't need to get rid of him they
just need to be like okay Joe uh we're
gonna get somebody else I'm gonna go
okay yeah I just don't buy the whole
like Yeah The Deep state is I mean right
after him I think it's his health right
like if they could have run him again
they would have but like again this
sounds terrible but like he doesn't seem
healthy this is a continued issue like
the other day he just announced he's
extending uh covet orders and his office
said May 11th everyone do it and then he
told reporters May 15th like he can't
keep basic important dates in mind right
he's a busy guy I guess he's got a lot
going on but like I think it's that
personally I think it's that he is not
healthy enough to run again and
therefore they have to replace him he
doesn't want wouldn't that happen
internally within the Democratic party
would they need this you know uh not if
he's gonna say oh I'm running I'm
running you cannot make me go on that
platform and say I'm not running I will
you know I'll see like if he digs his
heel to him what are they going to say
like I mean I think this has more to do
with making Trump look bad to be honest
and making Trump look bad I mean sorry
yeah um making him look better in
comparison to Trump oh he got rated too
but his wasn't that exactly his wasn't
that bad precisely
I think it's interesting yeah
I don't know man it's also confusing
because like we don't have the details
maybe they just screwed up they were
trying to cover this up they told the
National Archives not to say anything
but then CBS News got the story out and
now they're scrambling yeah I don't know
maybe that's it maybe Joe Biden can't
run there was that uh former Clinton
aide said this is it for him it's going
to be the end and I'm I'm sorry I just
don't feel that way I feel like Joe
Biden could walk onto Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody in their face
not kidding not kidding Trump was right
when he was talking about that yeah for
real the current state of American
politics is
if you're in the if you're in the cult
you're in the cult yeah there was a
there's a really great tweet I saw and
it said
if you were on the left you are allowed
to deviate from leftist economic policy
without reprisal but you cannot deviate
on gender ideology race ideology and
that explains exactly what the left is
and it's like that's an interesting
point if you're woke but you say
something like I don't know if universal
healthcare could work nobody cares yeah
it's like oh that's interesting right
but if you are pro-universal Healthcare
and you say hey that woke Up's nonsense
they call you right wing yeah I mean it
happens with minorities too you saw when
um all of the Muslims in Dearborn
protested against the sexualization of
children they called them terrorists you
know these are the same Muslims that
they're left pretended to defend during
the war on terror Etc now they're
calling them literal terrorists because
you know they're against woke
so I heard a story where it was like
apparently some woman was at a diversity
training and they said you know what's
say your name in pronouns said oh no
thank you I'm not religious and then
people started chuckling and then
everyone refused to give pronouns and
I'm like yeah maybe that happened it
does kind of sound like a and then
everyone clapped kind of story you know
because I don't I don't see people as uh
willing to stand up like I said Joe
Biden could walk on a Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and they'd still vote for
him yeah so I'm not I'm not convinced
that the average person who's aware of
what's going on with the corruption the
communism whatever you want to call it
is willing to actually stand up and say
anything because the the story that
breaks my heart we heard the other day
from Matt Strickland is that he defies
these lockdown orders he wins in court
he wins the political battle he was
right the whole time and he said people
call him and say what you did was great
how can I help you and he's like and he
says do what I did and go oh no no I
couldn't do that you know they'll come
after me and that that's how it feels
too many people are just like no no no
no don't look at me I'm gonna stay right
here where it's easy yeah they think
it'll will pass eventually but it's only
going to get worse we've seen this
throughout history
I mean the gender pronoun thing I've
made jokes saying like on Twitter saying
yeah there's going to be Republicans
with pronouns in their bios in 10 years
we'll see oh yeah yeah of course the
joke I made is that the Democratic party
is going to be hive mind Singularity pod
people versus transgender Communists and
that'll be the Republican party and you
know the Democrats will be the hive mind
AI people yeah and they'll be like hive
mind rights and they'll start arguing
that once you join the collective you
know you have a right like if a
non-citizen becomes part of the
collective they retain their voting
power because the collective is one one
unit or something like that then they're
going to be like we need a new system of
voting because ranked Choice voting
doesn't work anymore they're going to be
on like double bypass rank Choice
inversion voting where you know who you
vote for the third time gets counted
against you and some weird you know
anybody can vote and then they're going
to be like well he's in the hive now so
he's we are one and that means you know
he can he can vote and there's one vote
and we vote for Joe Biden again
Whoever has the best most feeling is the
one that would decide what the hive does
yeah so in order to vote in the future
you walk into a room close your eyes and
think real hard then we record it trust
us we're getting the account right we we
know yeah we go we got your vote yeah
and then they leave and it's like oh I
wonder you know who's gonna win and
they're like 99.9 Joe Biden you know I
don't think that the gender stuff is
just going to get worse you said earlier
like Chloe Cole gives me a lot of
inspiration I'm not sure if you're
familiar with her story she's like uh
she might be 19 at this point but she
had underwent uh surgery like
transgender surgery and had her double
mastectomy her breasts removed when she
was like 13 or 14. I don't want to get
the numbers wrong um but it's right
around that age I think it's 15 15. and
then realized what the pharmaceutical
companies were doing to her or or
enabling her to do to herself for profit
and uh came out and started speaking out
against it and she's immensely popular
right now with all sorts of people from
all ages so
I think we went through a horrible
period in the last six years of
pharmaceutical overreach in my opinion
yeah and and digging into these kids for
money
um but if you look at Europe and you see
how overly woke they are at you can tell
that the trajectory of the U.S is going
to follow that of Europe
right you know they've all had these
debates the bathroom debates and
everything and that their solution for
example for the bathroom thing is that
you know we're going to have unisex
bathrooms so I mean that's just one
example but if you want to see the
future of the US in terms of wokism and
and leftist ideology you look to
Scandinavia and Western Europe so in
California yeah true apparently
California is always five years ahead of
the rest of the United States yeah I
thought I covered this story a few years
ago it was talking about something
related to their weird policies and it
said historically the policies Implement
there make their way to the rest of the
country within five years so if you want
to figure out where things are going to
be in five years Look at California and
if you do well then any sane person is
going to get out of the city go to the
middle of nowhere and get some chickens
because otherwise you're gonna be
walking around New York gonna walk
around DC and there's going to be human
feces all over the streets and there
probably already are it's just that in
San Francisco it's way way worse in
Sacramento it's worse but that's that's
coming to a neighborhood near you
well and I would assume all the
migration that happened during the covid
lockdowns is going to influence that
right have you ever seen these maps of
like how people migrated and a lot of
them left California and left went to
States you wouldn't have predicted like
we always talk about this potentially
right they they bring their ideology and
their policies with them right they're
frustrated by what's happening in their
state but not by everything they like
just like one policy but they're going
to keep most of the others
yep naturally the country is just going
to move more left
in terms of socio-cultural I'm not I'm
not so convinced really uh yeah I think
it's going to be so we started seeing
this shift with Gen Z because leftists
don't have kids they have yours but that
that that only goes so far when you
start getting a pushback in the culture
war and I think mathematically it
doesn't matter whether or not they
indoctrinate kids I don't I think that
all that matters is the birth rate if
conservatives have even one kid per
family and Democrats have none kids per
family then the future even though will
be a population reduction will be way
more conservative and then people argue
yeah but the the woke are trying to
indoctrinate those kids yes but they
don't exist in large enough numbers so
if there's two leftist teachers trying
to indoctrinate your indoctrinate your
child then as they get older they're
dying off maybe they convert 10 maybe
let's say they convert 40 percent of all
conservative children into woke that
still means they are not replacing their
own ideological selves right and so over
long enough period like what's the
conversion rate you think for a
conservative kid into a woke kid I don't
think it's a particular percent it's
probably very low yeah you grow up in a
you grow up in a religious conservative
family you probably become slightly
libertarian as you get older but you're
still going to be somewhat conservative
people go through phases too I was I
went through like a real uh
post-modernist you can be whatever you
believe you are phase in my 20s and then
I realized the reality starts sitting
and I realize oh people will starve if
we don't get resources from point A to
point B you know the whole I believe is
not it's not good enough you know
reality it will slap you in the face
metaphorically if you just play them I
am what I think I am game yeah I think
you were making a point about
Generations right so if Generation Z if
you're seeing like a conservative turn
usually the next generation will be more
woke right so if you see backlash in a
certain no no no no no no you don't
think so uh research shows that every
generation starts skewing further and
further left but gen Z was the first
time in 100 years it actually ticked
back towards conservative because
something else I read um baby boomers
they were for there for that time period
they were woke you know they were
against the Vietnam War and Etc but then
Generation X that was the backlash
generation but uh well like they're all
more Progressive yeah on everything like
Boomers were resistant to gay marriage
gen xers were more accepting of it
Millennials were completely accepting of
it and then resulting in a favorable
cultural environment to make to legalize
or I should say to a codify not even
codify to rule in the Supreme Court that
it just is yeah and I think it went from
20 in the 90s to like 80 percent now I
mean it's considered one of the fastest
shifting cultural issues of all time
crazy I wonder how alpha is going to
turn out I mean if Zoomers are this way
then it's not about how they turn out
it's about who has the kids oh yeah
conservatives have more kids than
liberals and Liberals are now more
likely to sterilize and more likely to
abort their children so it's only a
matter of time I don't you know people
talk about all the politics and they're
like yeah but they're in schools and
they're indoctrinating and I'm just like
doesn't matter math you're not going to
change it like
over a long enough period of time it's
like saying
you know you go you go to a casino
because I was making the I said if I was
going to make a bet on you know Kamala
Harris people who are like Tim's got a
gambling problem because I always do the
gambling analogy but if you go to a
casino the house has an edge like how is
it that you can play on these games The
House Always Wins because in blackjack
they have a point five percent higher
chance of winning that that means you
can win a million dollars it doesn't
matter over the year they win point five
percent of all of those bets
statistically and that's all that
matters and that's what I'm talking
about with wokeness they can do whatever
they want they can indoctrinate this kid
and this kid they can get Greta tunberg
up on the big TV but over a long enough
period of time their attrition rate is
just too high if they want to abort
their kids and stare look a board in
their kids was one thing right the
leftists Liberals are substantially more
likely to get abortions than Christians
can serve it as Etc
and that right there is a hard
mathematical fact which is why many
people were saying for a while it
features Muslim because Muslims have
even more kids than Christians and
that's that's that's that's the number
that's all that matters however now
Liberals are sterilizing their kids so
that means it's almost like a
retroactive removal removal from future
Gene pools basically if you go back to
the 1990s and check abortion rates
you're going to be like we can do the
math liberals were aborting at this rate
can serve us at this rate you're going
to see more conservatives guess what we
are conservatives are having more kids
Liberals are having less kids why
because Liberals are aborting their
babies so in the early 2000s
conservatives were having I think it's
like 2.05 kids on average and Liberals
are having like 1.73 now what do we see
gen Z slightly more conservative in some
areas but fairly comparable to
Millennials now here's what they didn't
track for
when they were talking about abortion or
they weren't talking about abortion they
said do do liberals have kids do
conservative have kids and and the
answer was conservatives have more why
they were probably banging at the same
rate or similar rates but liberals were
having abortions reducing that number
now end the fact that those kids from
the 2000s who are 23 today have a higher
likelihood of being sterilized being uh
chemically castrated or transitioning or
just outright not wanting to have kids
as productive ideology so you add that
and now those people will not have
children so the the birth rate on the
left is going to go down further
personally I'm not a fan of any of that
stuff I think people should have
families and they'll enjoy it but if the
left doesn't want to have kids that's
the future that they've built yeah there
it is right don't make sense makes sense
I didn't know any of that actually it
assumes um you know a stable system
peaceful system
um it doesn't well because slavery is
real too like human slavery if if a
liberal Society were to go full militant
and just start killing and enslaving
children
um then they then they would be like
does you know then that would have won
you tell them you're telling me that you
think that if the the the circumstances
in the United States become
substantially more arduous
that it's then liberals will do better
no I think the ideology is destined for
failure that personal ideology of
cutting up kids and making them take
their penis off when they're 12 like
that's not gonna work and I'm not
species and I'm not saying that's like
in in massive numbers in the millions
it's in the thousands maybe even tens of
thousands and it may be reversing
because of what we're saying with people
like Chloe Cole but what I'm saying is
if you make a an easy comfortable system
you will start seeing more liberals and
leftists but they want gluttony more
than conservatives want gluttony that
many conservatives do so they abort and
sterilize their kids
but then you give them hardship
and conservatives are substantially more
likely to survive that hardship because
of meritocracy personal responsibility
and things like that so if it does
become a dictatorship all that means is
more liberals will struggle to succeed
maybe I was just thinking this will
succeed I was thinking of the Soviet
Union because that was a real liberal
Uprising they were all like wacky
radical leftists and uh they just killed
everyone else and took control
physically so enforced the ideology if
not for other countries around Earth and
and what one out in the end was I
wouldn't call it yeah it was oligarchy
yeah but then that period of the 90s
where you know oligarchs ruled
everything you know they liked Western
liberalism but now there's backlash
right and now they want to revive the
Soviet Union in Russia I mean Stalin is
the most popular figure in Russia and
they yeah literally want to go back to
the Soviet Union yeah how is that
happening who wants that and what do
they want exactly well I mean if you
look at polling data Western polling
data Stalin is the number one you know
most popular figure and if you talk to
Russians these days you know they want
they want to go back to the days of the
Soviet Union because that period of the
90s was just so horrible for the Russian
people and then Putin changed everything
when he came in in 2000 you know Russia
was declining economy was really bad and
then you know slowly he
re-industrialized and then changed the
economy for the better and now you know
Putin has been very good for the Russian
people well and maybe you can speak to
this but don't most Russian people not
want what modern Western values are
right and no they don't so I mean they
they admire the West because of you know
Hollywood and everything of Western yeah
because of the cultural power that the
West has but they are completely against
Western liberal values in fact there was
a bill that was just passed where they
expanded the anti-lgbt law that they had
and this was you know across the board
every party agreed with that they were
like no we're not going to have this uh
LGBT gender ideology propaganda in
Russia you know that's the the West so
it's hardening them even more so I saw
an interview with Putin a bunch of
college kids and they were like you
could see they wanted him to be like yes
we are now a liberal democracy but he
wasn't he was staying hard in there yeah
then uh they were like what should we
what uh senior or whatever they called
him Putin what should I do as a man in
Russia and Putin was like you should
learn to cook and he was like haha
everyone laughs he's like no as a real
man a Russian man there's like this
misogynist energy behind it all and that
that stood out to me that there's this
intense like misogyny in the Russian and
that and that guy and that guy and Putin
still was like no you should learn to
cook because the economy is about to go
to crap he didn't say that part but
that's what he was saying it's a very
Macho culture I mean I've been to Moscow
um and then you see it in the UFC as
well look at how all of the Russian
Fighters and everything you know they're
doing really really well they're
dominating the MMA world and that's part
of their culture you know men should be
men and women should be women you know
they women Embrace their femininity they
don't reject it and they don't try to be
more masculine like you know it's uh it
is here when you were saying that they
want to bring back people want to bring
that Soviet Union do they want do they
know what they want or is it just that
they want something better than what
they have and they're like well it's
actually
um uh older Russians that experience the
Soviet Union that wanted back the most
so it's interesting because it's the
opposite right because in the U.S you
have young Millennials that are more
socialist and then the older people here
uh they're like anti-socialist
anti-communist but in Russia younger
people they're more into you know
liberal values but then the older people
who experience communism they want the
Soviet Union back so it's like the
complete opposite it's just derived
through polls and things or polls yeah
mostly through polls and then you know
um I I don't necessarily go with like
lived experiences but that was my
experience in Russia as well how long
did you I was there for a month you know
I was there for work but uh it was a uh
enlightening experience because it
killed whatever progressivism and
leftism I had in me because it was a
totally different culture I'd never
really gone elsewhere aside from you
know like Western Europe so
um it's a very anti-progressive
anti-woke culture I mean it's pretty
much built in
it's very interesting going to Russia
you should have killed the wokism out of
you or like whatever progressivism I had
inside of me you know
um from you know like the Bernie days it
was just completely gone
um I became less I became more
Politically Incorrect you know but see
the thing with Bernie he wasn't uh he
wasn't woke yeah it wasn't the same
thing yeah he did that interview that
famous interview was like you got to
secure the borders you could have you
got to secure the bonus yeah and then um
they the world socialist website call
them a nationalist capitalist yeah
because he wanted to shut the borders
down and these people are Global
socialists yeah and then he changed his
whole shtick right in 2020 and that's
why I think he lost the primary because
you know he went full on the Ed pole and
the uh gender ideology and all that
stuff so it's like
yeah that's why he destroyed himself but
I'm sorry it sounded like a weirdo yeah
the regular people were like I don't
know what that's all about this guy's
crazy it went from unite the working
class to Identity politics in 2020.
that's how they do it that's how they
did with Occupy Wall Street they did
with Bernie Sanders yeah I feel like we
didn't mention it but it would be remiss
not to point out that universities are
also not quite as popular as they were
like you hear this all the time people
say you send your kid to University and
they move more left even if they were
raised in a conservative family but
studies are show I mean especially with
kovid we saw so many people opt not to
return to college and feel like it
wasn't worth it people are aware of how
much of a financial burden it is well
even Elon Musk is saying college is
useless yeah you know we'll want to work
at Tesla you don't need to have a
bachelor's degree right and this is more
and more also like if I'm going to take
on however much amount of debt to not
make that much money versus someone who
goes into a trade or any other thing who
gets a head start who's making more
money than you are even after your
four-year degree it doesn't make any
sense uh the national Clearinghouse put
out this study released from enrollment
from last year and they found that the
enrollment was down across the board
master's degrees any program definitely
down among undergraduates but it's uh
significantly down among women for the
first time in a really long time which I
find interesting yeah we've known for a
while that men are declining fewer men
are enrolling in college than women but
now just in the last year I can't say
it's a full-on trend but you saw twice
as many women didn't return to college
didn't enroll for the first time I think
I wonder what it is you know with like
uh
Elon Musk and many others I think Peter
Thiel talked about how college is
useless is we often said or the belief
was the reason men weren't going to
school going to college was because they
were lazy or they were living in their
parents basements and things like that
I'm wondering if dudes just figured it
out yeah I think men and women are
continually under the social pressure
where they're like you've got to go to
school and get a degree so you can be a
CEO because of patriarchy and you have
to prove yourself you have to prove that
you are just as good as all them in your
class by getting the degree whereas men
don't necessarily feel that same kind of
pressure and they are capable of doing
all kinds of things not that women
aren't but they're well I'll just pursue
this thing over here I also think
traditional learning environments aren't
suited for most men right like it's not
typical I mean we didn't do this for a
long time to have you also employers are
also saying that college graduates are
not prepared adequately for you know
working and everything yeah it's useless
it's just a holding pattern I mean at
one point academics like universities
and schools they really were sort of
interesting places they prepared you to
work but I don't think that's true more
I mean I went to a four University and I
was grateful for the experience but I
knew so many people who enrolled in
Master's programs because they didn't
want to be adults yet yeah and they also
say that college graduates lack critical
thinking skills because they're taught
to memorize I mean that's the American
education system especially in college
you're not rewarded for thinking
critically and analytically thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time